طبعا انا زي المشاهدين نشاهد هذه الصور
يعني لا ندري ان كان هذا مجرد فان ام غاز
مسيل للدموع تم اطلاقه من قبل رجال الامن
الفرنسيين على من يبدو هو الغاز مسيء للدم
واحده في هذه الصور واذا اشتباكات مستمره
بين المتظاهرين في هذه المظاهره اليوم اذا
السبت
رجال الامن الفرنسيين
الرئيس طبعا الفرنسي نذكر بعض تصريحاته
بعد هجوم امس الذي استهدف اذا اكراد في
فرنسا حيث قال ان اكراد فرنسا قد استهدفهم
هجوم شنيعه حسب وصفه في قلب باريس وقلوبنا
كما يقول مع الضحايا والذين يصارعون من
اجل الحياه وعائلاتهم واحبابهم
بطلب منها طبعا يستقبل قائد شرطه باريس
مسؤوليه الجاليه الكرديه صباح اليوم بينما
اعلن هؤلاء عن تظاهر اذن للاقليه الكرديه
ظهر اليوم في العاصمه الفرنسيه وهذه بعض
الجوانب منها كما نشاه